what is going on here citizens of the
rejection it's time for the final
episode of One Piece season one I want
to say thank you to all who have joined
us on this journey thank you Aaron for
being here with me are you excited Aaron
I am born excited I'm I'm so excited I
could keep it short okay you've got
somewhere to be geez you're taking too
long me happy we are we this is dragon
out this is dragging way too long Dragon
Ball Z this is dragging out please we
gotta we gotta get some tracking you
know we got I'm not dragging it now
you're trying to drag it up dragging it
up we're saying dragging like 15. let me
look up what it means to drag it out
really
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated also be sure to
subscribe and click that notification
Bell for something that we might cover
in the future bowling through action
watch long we're singing with your own
copy available for super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page thank you to
all have joined for just one piece alone
but we cover several things over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included let's get to it
thank you
oh it's her getting her tattoo
it's like branding yeah she's just a kid
when she got it too dang man
[Music]
damn you got any tattoos no
you pay me 100 million Berry when you're
able to pay
you and your town will have your freedom
map collector wow she had the money and
then he just stole it right from her and
I like a pirate who used to keep my
promises no you don't it's a liar oh
[__] dang it really burnt that [__] down
the chico told us about your sacrifice
we didn't know can you ever forgive us
there's nothing to forgive I was kind of
a dick
this is my fight
no
hours this is our fight
right guys finally I got to cut
something but how are we going to be our
long we saw what he did at bratia every
creature has a weakness even bulletproof
ones you don't have to do [__]
I won't hesitate
oh that's a cool one I would get each
one of these logos each one of these
title sequins as a shirt they've all
been pretty cool I have received word of
pirate activity at Coco Village what
what oh
Pirates
there is a new Chrome in these parts led
by a ruthless killer the pirate in a
strong hat
Savage
would be stupid enough to attack us
yeah let's go
[Applause]
let's go oh yeah
yes yes
oh hell yeah
oh
nice
way to go buddy
yep sounds about right great camera work
all around yeah all around very well
shot
stop wearing them when I was
12. I never cleaned it up they just
stopped love it there
is for a rainy day
what a big blade
oh yeah this guy Spire fire spitter
great shots again nice
I loved it this Zoom board is like a
shredded like an anime action
[Music]
that was nice it looks like someone's
backyard
[Laughter]
rich man's pool
not me
you you could have been spared
taking your place right by my side yeah
the deal you betrayed me
overboard maybe for giving me a hundred
million
like what nothing can stop me from
taking the East blue and every other sea
after that pirate king
not even flinching could you have used
her so effectively yes
mm-hmm
yeah they're always bleeding yeah he's
holding on to the blade
yeah she's a person with wants and
dreams of her own guy
anyone else who tries to hurt other
people or alongside the hell are you
talking okay
I wasn't there for those events
get out of here Nami but Luffy
I got
this you can escape
round two are long
have the motivation of friendship now
so Swift
maybe you should take a break
maybe you ought to get back in the
kitchen
Luffy needs us
oh great that was dope you don't know
what Luffy needs I know he needs my
cooking you mean putting two slices of
bread together
trust me I can help you guys win this
thing oh gosh
yes yes oh so much better than I even
remember
I'm gonna get out of here kiddos I'd
love to make things right but it's time
to exit stage left
I guess not
oh damn
oh unless you probably put some stuff on
it there's no way you're bleeding that
much this has to be a trick too bad
little one
just when we're starting to have some
fun you really he really hunted him down
yeah he really singled out USA
hey Netflix
what happened to the element of surprise
my skin is tougher than bullets
maybe you should try one of my new
patented fire rounds I don't catch fire
maybe you don't
but the bottle the alcohol does
whoa
nice the Great Captain uza fails another
notorious villain
the first time I've ever done something
okay you strike down my brothers
okay against the might of my fish
your fish man karate
fist in 3D three-dimensional fisty cuffs
kick him in the face Angie
oh okay this guy's good
also wouldn't draw get his swords fixed
damn it
let's go
yes oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a great new teeth yeah he is
gross
no thank you
[Music]
damn it is Karate
kicks can break a ship skill that's
nothing you should have seen Seth's
kicks when he found the next show in the
creme brulee I can't nothing
[Music]
no
burn the maps burn them maybe I can't
beat you
but I can destroy
everything you've built what you talking
about Willis burn it
[Music]
nice outsmart him Army is a fool to ever
faith in such a weak and Patriots
[Music]
God I love him so much yeah
[Laughter]
what a reference what a call back
follow me
[Laughter]
straight through
that's great she's like who's this guy
who's the new guy
[Music]
that was so cool burn the maps let's
just smack the it's a lantern lanterns
thank you smack the Torches
oh
my God yes
that was the last thing I expected
[Music]
Luffy slingshot your way out of there
yo that's crazy he's fine he's made out
of rubber
right I love the consistency of Zorro
and Sanji still with their hands in
their pockets yeah so cool always
you are our friend
Let's Go
the music too straw hat for life baby
let's go
I even got Zorro smiling okay okay
he's going to be king of the Pirates
I love it love it love it love it I mean
our Long's not dead though oh probably
not I'm gonna need these recipes too you
should really write a cookbook
it could be talked into offering some
private lessons
nice try
why do none of these women want to sleep
with him I don't understand he's
Charming I don't understand
[Laughter]
pulled my trusty slingshot
like single-handedly defeated arlong and
his deadly crew
With a Little Help
all right
cheers
we're gonna have done it without him
Luffy man
hooray
I Love Lucy all right the Marines oh
[__] I forgot about them arrest them
I saw the story Cocoa Village you have
your orders Cadet no no finally you do
realize there are severe punishments for
disobeying direct orders
disagree with those orders sir join the
Pirates join them
me too yes I called it from the first
episode
wow last chance
Give It Up
it's not really my thing
hmm
you're gonna fight him do you have
powers too he's gotta
I mean did have he did throw that that
ball earlier I don't want to fight you
Grandpa
fighting me your entire life damn
come on man you just defeated R along
you can do this I think Grandpa's
stronger than our long got that old man
shrinks just crush the whole village
Luffy just give him one of those claps
give him a little Thunderclap or do that
kick again do that super kick because I
trained you better than this
you did
oh he's gonna slingshot himself yeah
[Applause]
yeah I didn't think that was gonna work
I told you
you aren't ready you can hit me all day
long I could do this all day but I'm
never giving up on my dream and I will
find the one piece
Pirates
is it every episode
[Laughter]
yep yep
have it your way lower your weapons
you're stubborn just like me
but I know who you are boy I just needed
to make sure you knew it too what a long
journey right to find that out he's the
whole Marine Fleet Texas grants
he wasted government money to test his
grandson wonder if that's going to cause
the Marines to question his leadership
because he just let these Pirates go
they've been chasing for like six months
I can move forward with my head held
high that's why you always want it right
I'm sorry I didn't understand the
sacrifices you made for me now open that
over your thigh you know that Citrus you
want the juice
so messy cyan it was a napkin or
something I hope you'd be proud of me
she was always proud of you
how's your own
the new tattoo worth it do you really
have to leave
I do need to go no matter how far you go
you will always have a place here to
return to this will always be your home
hell yeah
my God there's lyrics oh
[Music]
Citrus pinwheel that's what her mommy
made her I have an orange tree do you
eat oranges like that I love oranges I
wanted to show you something
hell yeah
that's that's a lot of berry it's the
highest bounty in the East blue
you're a wanted man now
exactly what I wanted
you just wanted to be wanted the whole
time I guess this is goodbye then
goodbye means forever we're just done
with Kobe now
be a good Marine be a good pirate oh
they both will be they both will be they
can navigate the Seas Together live in
your dreams what a beautiful thing
unless movies wanted posted not just
Luffy
this is stupid this is going to make
things much harder with that price on
your head every Bounty Hunter and that
useful will be cunning for you season
dose
then it's a good thing we're not staying
in the East blue going to the West Blue
we're going to the Grand Prime
oh hey hey and the bird too yay
we're shanks
[Music]
oh they're all coming back all the
characters we met along the way
up
[Music]
then all right buggy yep buggy yep and
then our uh our mustache a guy that
killed a little [__] myself if you don't
I will
team up the Fire Woman yeah
team up what about the other guy what
about the butler guy the odds of all
three of them in the same room are not
likely right now
that's Season Two Season Two I'm ready
to accept my punishment following orders
doesn't make you a good Marine it's
following your code all men have their
own brand of Justice
and you both followed yours hmm nice oh
yeah my training methods have been
called the worst kind of punishment
you gotta train us yourself well you
want to get stronger don't you learn how
to fight
yes teachers not a villain he's not I
was not expecting that um I want to show
people that rogano azaro isn't the only
one that knows how to use swords oh I
need a new haircut the old Chef was
right
it is your turn they're the right age
ah our guys back
that's the butler oh he's gonna be
teaming up with the butler huh oh no no
shakes
Shanks come on lads we're in the
presence of a mighty warlord of the sea
show a little
oh respect see you monkey see Luffy's
want to post her please
I recently ran into someone who might be
of interest to you
Thursday
you really did it no way it's Lucy he's
a pirate he's a captain wait which one
is usop's Dad
I don't know bring out the reserve booze
boys thought you were hungover Shanks
Gosling I can't wait till they reunite
I'm so excited
oh hell yeah Journey
thoughts anytime you want
tangerines not oranges a bit odd but I
like it a little bit of home with you I
love it
perfect
we actually have something for you too
is it what I think it is
[Music]
the Jolly Roger beautiful how'd they do
that without him realizing I love it
love it love it love it
[Music]
ill adorable son of a [__] right
good River or a canal or something but
it doesn't make any sense these
elevations show a mountain I mean how
can a river go up a mountain no how can
a river go up a mountain hmm
draw that
oh hands on deck for a cast off ceremony
stuff ceremony
full circle
barrel and now they're about to oh my
God hero shot
Arrow shiny or blue
oh
hell yeah their childhood dreams I'm
gonna be the world's greatest Swordsman
what do you want Mommy I'm gonna draw a
map of the world okay all right what do
you want usab
hi
I'm gonna find your dad
I'm gonna become a bright Warrior of the
sea that's right yeah I mean that one's
more achievable than the other ones but
yeah man you got this oh
let's put our feet in what do you want
to do Greg I want to reach 1.4 million
subscribers
there it is there it is the one piece
those are another it's a tease or what's
the cotton what's to come what's to come
we don't know
who's this Feller
uh-oh burning burning Luffy's thing this
is when an ending explained ruins shits
for us
thank you
well cool as non-watchers of the anime
I don't know what that was about
the anime right there all right let's
skip to it
skip to it let's just get in it
okay that was fun all right Aaron let's
look at the time and then we got to get
you out of here
10 minutes I'm gonna wrap this [__] up
buddy what did you think I loved it I
love the entire show I love this episode
I thought it was incredible yeah we
started with the stuff with Arlon or
arlong and seeing Our Heroes finally
come together working together and
doing all the cool things the heroes
that decide to be a team do from usab's
moment taking down the the one fish guy
to Luffy taking down arlong to Sanji and
uh Zora working together it was so cool
to Kobe realizing his Arc and The
[__] kind of getting his Arc too and
then Luffy coming full circle becoming
The Wanted pirate he always wanted to
this was like dream fulfillment
for everybody involved or all of our
characters you know that they're on our
their journey to become the heroes that
they really want to be and I thought it
was great you know it's it was a
live-action anime that succeeded at
being a live-action anime and it did it
with flying colors you know it got us to
endear the audience to these characters
and their they made a believable and
yeah man it was just
it was just so much fun it made my heart
so happy and I am thoroughly invested in
one piece after years of people telling
me to watch this thousand plus episode
show I haven't seen all thousand plus
episodes I haven't even seen the anime
but I have seen this and I love it and I
understand the hype now
it was it was great and yeah I I love
seeing I think the thing about this show
that made it so great was this this
persevering heart of dream fulfillment
and teamwork and realizing that you can
do anything with
little help or you can do anything with
a dream and a vision and pursuing that
dream pursuing that vision and
perseverance
yeah I think overall this was one of the
most fun I've had watching a show in
some time uh because it had heart it had
incredible action
it had beautiful choreography
it had beautiful set design incredible
music
and yeah it just passed on all colors
for me
I think maybe
some things could have been fleshed out
a little bit more or rather like given
some time I still think usab could
become more useful in the future because
it kind of feels like they're like they
had his two episodes they're like we'll
figure it out eventually but you know
he's he's
he's kind of funny
um but yeah I think everything else
really uh really worked for me even the
turn of Garb being not so bad of a guy I
was like okay I can get behind this not
what I was expecting but hey I'm with it
I'm with the journey and yeah I think
for the time being that is what I have
to say about it I really really enjoyed
it Greg what did you think well
I think that this show was excellent on
all accounts
it got me thinking in the Final Shots of
like what does one piece mean or like
what is the interpretation I can at
least have of it and I feel like they're
all like pieces to this one Unity you
know this whole team the straw hat
Pirates each like it's not it starts off
as just Luffy's show and then as it
progresses it's like every one show yeah
so it's all these pieces that all become
one even though they're searching for a
thing called one piece I love the idea
of unity and that's so much of what it's
about is the the power of companionship
the power of cooperation the power of
friendship the power of belief in others
the power of self-belief it's just a lot
of very positive messaging uh throughout
it and it even thematically tied in with
his grandpa which surprised the [__] out
of me uh out of everything that every
turn that happened the most unexpected
one I thought for some reason the
grandpa might let him go
I didn't expect it to be the reasoning
for what happened there
oh yeah and like not even because it's
straight up had this like shift where it
wasn't even jarring it didn't even feel
like a cop out because the whole season
is like [__] he's the villain he's
the Baddie he's a bad guy the big bad
the ultimate and then he reveals what's
really up
and he doesn't even like punish the
other two no instead finds like oh
that's the kind of spunk I'm looking for
you know and it all fit with the
character yeah it didn't go against the
character it's like well that's kind of
uh I normally I'm left here baffled and
kind of a oh you kind of just undermined
a lot and to hear him like no this
actually lines up with everything yeah
at all tracks like he's a tough [__]
and everything I'm not saying like he's
like a nice person
um but he's not the villain you know and
I or at least right now right and and I
like that Nuance too that they have of
understanding that not all Pirates are
bad and not all Marines are bad people
you know and um that it's all about like
the power of the individual you know the
uniqueness of that one person who can
really make a difference and it's a lot
of that too is like the one person who
can make a difference so I thought a lot
of there's a lot of great strength here
and uh yeah you know incredible fight
scenes all around I like the camaraderie
with everyone I like the back and forth
of Zorro and Sanji
um everyone had a character Arc here
pretty much kind of you saw but everyone
everyone here had like a really clear
character and it gets you excited for
what's to come uh for for the future for
these guys and setting up the stakes of
it while not also feeling like they're
rushing just to set up season two like I
still feel like I got a complete Journey
here of them becoming the Assembly of
this team while looking for more to come
like I think it's a near perfect season
one you know there are some sometimes in
the
directing where I was like nah I feel
like they might have like overshot it a
little bit like I mean just like shoot
him like maybe this looks like not as
I don't know you know what I don't even
want to bother nitpicking
I don't even want to bother honestly I
don't like it was it like the end of the
day a word is hard on a sleeve
throughout and and it's there's nothing
like it there's no other live action
show like it there's nothing like it and
uh I've seen you know me either yeah so
uh I think it was I think it's excellent
unique and from what I understand a
pretty damn good adaptation as well and
um I I can't wait for the next season
because I feel like whatever things I
would have nitpicked about some of the
ways it was shot or maybe looked or
maybe they're like I didn't really have
the budget to do this certain moment
here or there
again I'm probably a nitpick because it
was so [__] rare when I thought it
I feel like with the amount of success
the shoe had it's just you're gonna
lucky so much it already looked great
it's gonna imagine like just how much
more refined it's gonna look in season
two just how much they already threw a
lot of money on this first season
imagine how much better it's gonna look
in season two better some of the
cinematography will look with some of
the makeup in this in the visual effects
and all that like for the vast majority
already looked amazing I'm like oh man
it's already gonna look better than so
yeah I I I'm very very excited I think
this was an excellent experience and I
hope that one with the hope the weight's
not too long because you know the
Netflix shows can take a while plus the
strikes and everything oh yeah [__]
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's gonna be a long time uh but
the weight I think will be worth it and
um music excellent everything around I
feel like if you just take all
everything we've said about every
episode that's the whole series review
yeah that's the whole point and I think
uh some of those things I was missing
from our long in the last episode kind
of gave me more of that here that I was
looking for
um so yeah everything all around it was
great guys um thank you all for being
here thanks Aaron for being on the
stream with me uh it's pretty sure
you're sticking around I know you got
something to really get through that you
paid for a long time ago
thank you guys so much again and uh keep
a look out I'm sure there's going to be
something else great to cover
um all right well I won't be I'm done oh
we're done thank you guys bye
[Music]